throughout standing afters join us to
present the first music award of the
evening
and Andy Garcia
the category is original musical or
comedy score the nominations are as
varied as the art of music itself here
are the nominations for original music
and comedy score abouts life by Randy
Newman
Moulin music by Matthew Wilder lyrics by
David Zippo and orchestral score by
Jerry Goldsmith
patch Adams by Marc Shaiman
the Prince of Egypt music and lyrics by
Stephen Schwartz orchestral score by
Hans Zimmer Shakespeare in Love written
by Stephen Moore Beck
and the Oscar goes to Stephen Warbeck
for Shakespeare love
this is the first Academy Award for
Steven Warbeck who also composed the
score for mrs. Brown
it's a very very exciting moment thank
you very much especially exciting
because John Madden's such a
fantastically stimulating person to
collaborate with so thank you John
thank you to the Academy thank you to
Sarah Jessica Herbert Matilda and thank
you to my mother and father thank you to
the lovely producers without whom we
wouldn't be here or the people involved
in this thank you to William Shakespeare
bertolt brecht and the kippers for
inspiring me to write music for the
theater and other things and thank you
thank you to all the friends who worked
on the music without whom it will just
be squiggles on a piece of paper John
Parrott Shelley Eleanor Al Berger
cristobal nicking man Martin Robertson
Paul Geary and Frank thank you very much
indeed it's lovely thank you
pre-show hosting to present the next
award Oscar winner Geena Davis
the best film scores can stand on their
own two feet as pure compositions
tonight choreographer Debbie Allen has
gathered five of the most talented
dancers in the world from Spain Joaquin
Cortes from New York
Savion Glover and Ty Jimenez from the
Kirov Academy Rasta Thomas and from
Fosse Desmond Richardson they will now
interpret the music of the five
nominated original dramatic film scores
and for the fourteenth time the Academy
Awards orchestra will be conducted by
Oscar winner bill Conti
you
you
you
the nominees for Original dramatic score
are David Hurst elder for Elizabeth
we come up here life or life is
beautiful Randy Newman for Pleasantville
John Williams for Saving Private Ryan
hans zimmer or the Thin Red Line
and it Oscar goes to Nicola pavani for
life is beautiful
Nikola Giovanni has scored such films as
ginger and Fred and Federico Fellini's
introduced uh this is his first Academy
Award
now it's impossible for me in this
moment speak about my emotion in English
I can tell just thank you to the jury
then to the Academy
thank you Robert
I want to be in that dance number
I'm doing but Debbie says she killed me
if I put one toe on to the stage so I
dropped out now
our next presenter could be seen
starring in primary colors in which he
played a president so convincingly that
George Stephanopoulos is writing a
tell-all book about him right now ladies
and gentlemen two-time Oscar nominee mr.
John Travolta
they called him the voice the chairman
of the board and old blue eyes the kid
from Hoboken who called the shots and
beat the odds he was most envied admired
an influential entertainer of our time
he was Sinatra Francis Albert Sinatra
multi-million selling recording artist
and Academy Award winning actor when
making a film he believed that the first
take was the best take but he brought to
the party such intelligence such
compassion and emotional depth that very
often the first take was all he needed
to sell the scene the character and
ultimately the audience director Martin
Scorsese has taken some of the
highlights of the Sinatra legacy on film
and created a portrait of a proud and
charming man who will be missed but
never forgotten